I feel so left out because all of my
friends are constantly on social media
and I can't be on any right now I'm a
social media addict I look at my phone
when I wake up in the morning and when I
go to sleep constantly refreshing it and
using basically every form of social
media possible I one like Facebook and
Instagram multiple times a day because
how am I gonna know what people are
doing with their lives every 10 minutes
maybe every five minutes I'm looking at
my phone I can sit without doing
anything creative so I take a lot of
pictures even though I'm not a big
social media user I'm very nervous about
it I'm more so lurk unlike other people
stuff and see what they're doing and
then like only share what I want to
share on social media I like to call it
like my highlight reel because I show
like the better parts of my life when
I'm feeling insecure I take pictures of
myself and put it online for validation
and usually it works I feel better about
myself so I'm gonna go through and
delete all of my apps I'm starting today
wait can I start tomorrow so it's been
about 15 minutes since I deleted all my
social media and I already don't know
what to do I've just been refreshing my
email hoping for something good we just
arrived in Hong Kong and we're on the
subway I really want to take
Instagram picture right here do you
think ol last no shielding all night by
day seven don't even do my no turn it
out it was definitely challenging just
because it's so automatic for me to
always like just be on my phone it's now
day three there's different like things
in the news that I've missed so I've had
to have people updating me all this view
and no one to share it with so many
pictures but you know I can't put it
anywhere no no stories no snapchat so
what do we do I keep trying to check
Facebook not just to post stuff but just
you know check out what everybody's
doing I guess it's just become a habit
to like fill my every second of every
day with content instead of being on
social media I've been hiking with
Angela time I come to Runyon I always
like Instagram a photo of me on top but
it's the whole world out there I think
I've also always said that social media
is a big time waster and I thought that
that was such a big reason why I don't
get any work done I'm currently looking
up Harry Potter houses I am going a
little crazy because I'm just like I
don't know what's going on in the world
and I don't know where my friends at do
it's my mom's birthday I haven't been
able to post anything for her so what I
did was I wrote out exactly what I would
post for her and I texted it to her it
actually felt really good it's movie
night and all my friends are on her
phone's so today was my first
anniversary with my boyfriend that was
really nice being able to keep my mind
off of social media and focusing on what
I was actually doing which was a really
great night
[Music]
what people used to do whatever social
media I would taste this is on Facebook
right now how my sister is is this my
kitchen I got really hard to like be
over terrible this is a terrible cruel
and unusual I struggled a lot that felt
like one of the longest weeks of my life
it was actually really great I need to
do this more often there's something
about this experience that changed some
little things in me I accidentally read
downloaded Facebook and that was going
on in the world
I felt like I was like cheating in a
relationship I realized that I gained a
lot of my news not just like my friends
news but actual international news from
social media which is super bad and he
started realizing that all this like
browsing was getting in the way of
making meaningful conversations happen I
was asking a lot of questions to myself
now that there was no bubble where I
could be all the time I was very
conscious of all the people around me
definitely feel like this experience
taught me to live more in like the
present moment you know doing things
simply for sharing it with somebody to
gain validation is kind of meaningless
and empty in a way I'm kind of sad that
I'm excited I'm so excited I'm just like
counting down as 42 notifications I
gained more followers oh let's I missed
you my friend we're going back online
oh I have to login I don't know if I
remember my password
[Music]